♪ ♪
>> Sandra: STAGGERING NEW
NUMBER SHOWING THE EXTENT OF THE
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
ACCORDING TO CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION.
171,000 IMMIGRANTS WERE CAUGHT
ENTERING THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
JUST LAST MONTH.
NUMBERS NOT SEEN IN DECADES.
AT THE SAME TIME I TIME I SEE A
SHARP DECREASE IN DEPORTATIONS
AND ARRESTS OF IMMIGRANTS WHO
ARE ENTERING THE U.S. ILLEGALLY.
TWO LAWMAKERS WORKING ACROSS THE
AISLE ON A BILL TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM, CONGRESSMAN JOHN KATKO
AND HENRY CUELLAR WILL BE
JOINING US LIVE IN MOMENTS BUT
WE BEGIN WITH
WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES.
HI, WILLIAM.
>> THREE THINGS AT PLAY HERE.
WHAT AND HOW MUCH TAXPAYERS ARE
PAYING TO HOUSE THE IMMIGRANTS,
AT CONVENTION CENTERS AND
HOTELS.
$800 A DAY.
VERSUS $75 A DAY FOR THOUSANDS
OF EMPTY BEDS.
HHS HAS 13,000 MIGRANT CHILDREN
IN SHELTERS.
IT RELEASES 60% OF FAMILIES YET
I.C.E. HAS 15,000 EMPTY BEDS
UNDER CONTRACT AT $75 A DAY,
ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS A DAY.
BEDS GO EMPTY AND I.C.E.
TAXPAYERS SPENT 8 MILLION TENT
10 MILLION FOR CHILDREN IT COULD
DEPART BUT WON’T.
REDUCING ICE ARRESTS BY 65% AND
THE AGENCY CUT DETENTIONS
BECAUSE OF THE RISK OF COVID.
JUDGES ORDER THE RELEASE OF 3700
INMATES.
1800 CHARGED WITH OR CONVICTED
OF HOMICIDE, ASSAULT, CHILD
ABUSE, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, RAPE,
DUI AND SEXUAL ABUSE OF A CHILD.
>> WHEN YOU’RE TELLING THEM TO
RELEASE THEM, IT’S NOT SOME
HAPLESS INDIVIDUAL WHO GOT
ARRESTED BY I.C.E. FOR A BROKEN
TAIL LIGHT.
THOSE ARE NOT THE CASE IS IN
CUSTODY.
THE MOST EGREGIOUS CASES THAT
I.C.E. IS BEING FORCED TO
RELEASE.
>> I ASKED ABOUT THE BED
SURPLUS.
I CEASES IT CONTRACTS IN ADVANCE
TO GET THE PRICE.
HHS REFUSING TO SAY HOW MUCH
THEY ARE PAYING FOR THE
CONTRACTS IN SAN DIEGO, HOUSTON